- 全正小哥
- 欢迎收看财经小学堂
- 我们今天邀请到的来宾是全正小哥
- 嗨 大家好
- 每次看小哥的线上课程
- 我都觉得小哥好神啊
- 好像买什么都会赚
- 甚至一天赚百万
- 而且真的有越来越多的会员跟学生
- 来分享他的对账单
- 蛮多的
- 像今天就有很多人分享
- 建策的地方子
- 是是是
因为其实注股票就跟统计一样
我们统计这个形态
因为地板股的形态发生之后
那我们就有个进场的SOP
那经由这个SOP
哇你就知道说你应该在什么时候进场
那就很容易隔天
你会有一个获利出场的机会
那所以今天有很多人就赚了
因为我也替他们来开心的
好所以小哥今天要来分享他一个赚钱通道
听说这个赚钱通道跟他喜欢夹娃娃很有关系哦
对
我们现在讲这个娃娃
小哥很厉害
是个高手
这个夹娃娃就是
一你要有兴趣
二你要啃头钱
其实这两个
你有兴趣啃头钱
大概后面你再摸索一下技术
其实不会很难
尤其在日本的娃娃也不会很难
那这个相片呢是我在那个下关
你知道下关吗
不知道
在那个你知道马关条约吗
马关条约有听过
马关条约呢
这个在日本叫做下关
那我为什么要搭电车呢
因为我要从下关回到了九州
下关是在本州
从下关回到九州搭这个电车的时候
拍了照片
这是最后一班车
最后一班车
这个我夹了一对娃娃
回到饭店
那这个对假娃呢
很感兴趣啊
因为在日本夹的娃娃呢
一呢它是蛮漂亮的
我给你看一下
娃娃都很漂亮
娃娃很漂亮
所以呢拿回台湾送人的时候
大家都很开心
因为你在台湾呢
找到这么好看的娃娃
那这些娃娃通常都是在上课的时候
送给学院
不然我们家也没放不了那么多
那这个比较特别的是我去九州讲的
这个在九州的左鹤甲
左鹤是全日本最无聊的一个县市
最无聊的一个地方
为什么最无聊
因为有部电影叫做左鹤的超级阿嬷
为什么讲左鹤呢
因为他们就找到最偏远的地方
其实越偏远的地方越好夹
越偏远的地方爪子越有力
所以这第一天我先去观望一下
看里面可以夹什么
所以第一天夹这个
大概十几只
等到第二天混熟了
混手之后
两倍的战利品
这不止两倍
第二天大概四倍
四倍
四倍怎么多
这么多啊
第三天
第三天要回家
这样怎么带回台湾
每次拍完这张照片
看完这张照片
很多人都会跟你有一样的问题
怎么带回来
这个就得去他们的超级市场
跟他去要直向
然后我们也还有带压缩袋去
不过后来我们不喜欢压缩袋
因为压缩袋一压缩
那个脸都变皱
然后娃娃就变老娃娃
不用压缩袋
我们就发一纸箱
塞到纸箱
然后捆绑
你只要纸箱有残胶袋
有捆绑的袋就可以拖运
但是你假如一个人去
你假如是自由行
你这样拖运会太多箱
所以我们是跟团去的
跟团去团的行李就一起算
讲了这么多
非常开心
讲完的娃娃很多都送给学员
送给学员之前都请他们先拍个照
因为那娃娃就要离我远去
以后就看不到他们了
所以有些娃娃我都还记得说
他大概送给谁
他有点印象
那为什么要从夹娃娃开始讲
因为赵娃娃跟股票的相关性
我们都从这个条件来看
抓娃有两个条件
第一个爪子要有力
在台湾很多
抓得起来
台湾很多娃店现在都倒了
他们有个很大问题
他们是摸摸爪
摸摸爪就爪子下去摸一下
摸一下就走了
通常你投了10块之后
你就很气
你就骗子
你从此就不再踏进那家店
那家店后来就会倒
所以第一个要有力
第二个呢
当板要够低
假如它很有力
就当板很高 那也没有
当板很高呢 它也夹不出来
因为它有力 抓起来之后
它们都会丢回去嘛
所以当板太高也没有用
所以抓完了就这两个条件
爪子有力 低当板
那我们在看股票的时候呢
也是一样要有一些条件
第一个 抓完爪子有力
那股票呢 就筹码要有主力
有主力才会公股
对 从而有主力
这个股票就比较会涨
那第二个呢
这个最好是股价经过整理
那布林贷宽载
整理的时候呢
它的股价会越来越压缩
那我们有一个通道
就叫布林通道
那布林通道画起来呢
它贷宽就很窄
那越窄的呢
这个一喷出
它的行情就越大
所以这跟股票一样
有这两个条件
所以布林通道就是
小哥最喜欢的一个赚钱通道
只是这个好像也是跟统计学有关
对跟统计有关
其实做交易跟统计
做交易跟统计有很大的关系
我读大学
读研究所的时候
因为我们大学还没学
我统计学学的最好
他其实他学的很烂
因为我觉得统计学很有意思
那后面研究股票之后
我觉得哇
不管是大数据啊
或是一些
像我们刚刚讲的地盘谷
那其实都是应用到统计方面
那这步林通道呢
它也是一个统计的东西
那步林通道呢
我们又称了这个步林轨道
还有保利加通道
那这里呢会有三条线
中轨、上轨跟下轨
步林通道就是有三条线
那中轨呢就是N天的这个
简单移动平均线
那通常我们讲N天
在一般的电脑里面设计都是20天
均线20个交易日
上轨有的人又叫上通道
他是利用中轨加两个标准差
下轨又叫下通道
是中轨减两个标准差
这两个标准差
坊间有人会去改他的参数
有人会改2.1 2.2 1.9
我是觉得可以不用改
因为改了又麻烦
不用改
一般来讲我们都用2.0
通常按常态分布95%机会
股价会在上轨跟下轨之间震荡
那震荡又有分
带宽的震荡跟带宽比较窄的震荡
那这两个呢
我们今天就会讲说怎么做
这个宽跟窄
其实就是股价一个震幅
对 最近的震幅
所以要看它宽
是就可以找买卖点
对 它政府震的越大的话
那上面的通道就越有意义
上轨就越有意义
那政府震的越小的话
那上轨呢
这个就等突破而已
这两个不同的面向
带宽很宽的时候
那上面就是个压力
那带宽很窄的时候
那上面不是压力哦
那上面呢
你等它突破之后
哇这个是要追的点
是这样子看
那我们就来定一下这个带宽
这个小哥带宽定义啊
那很简单
你就把上通道出去
下通道减义就好
很简单的定义
那这算出来呢
假如是5%以下呢
叫做窄
举例来说
下通道100
上通道105
105除100
1.05
1.05-1
0.05
0.05就是5%
5%叫做窄
10%正常
20%以上就叫寬
在布林轨道上面
很多人都没有去注意到带宽
其实带宽才是重要
带宽越宽的话
上面跟底下
它的压力跟支撑就越明显
我们知道了宽跟窄
我们还是要来运用
就是什么时候才是好的买点跟卖点
对 举来说了
我们来看这个案例
那这案例是去年的一个案例
一开始在这个位置
在这个位置它的通道底是80.1通道底是76那7680.1到底几%呢考虑一下来我们看来76涨到80块多少钱
4块
这样吗
那76涨4块
大概涨几%
大概5%左右
对 厉害
那一下就算出来
很简单
76块
因为70块涨5%就3.5%
80块涨5%就4块
对 因为涨4块
大概是5%左右
对 没错
我们这样一算出来
大概是5.4%
是
那带宽5.4%
在我们定义上就算宰
那宰呢
宰只要怎么样
只要一打开
一打开就叫我们就往上开不灵
你要记得
只要他带宽宰
然后往上一打开
那就是个好买点
带宽宅
就是一个讯号
对 就是讯号
然后带宽宅多宅
5%就叫宅
那5%到10%的是普通宅而已
那5%以下非常宅
越宅呢
它会那个效果越明显
那通常我们看到这种带宽宅
往上一涨
那这种都要追的
都要追
那追了之后呢
很多人都会问啊
那出场点在哪边
那出商点就是
沿着上通道你都不要卖
然后什么时候才卖呢
一离开上通道就卖
一离开
一离开就卖
就整根K棒
离开上通道你就卖掉
就好了
就这样子很简单
那这个上通道价格
我们可以来看这个上通道的邪律
那上通道呢
这个我们有个邪律的定义
那邪律定义也很简单
一般方间
有的人对邪律他都会讲角度
角度他是错的
有人跟你讲角度
你就知道他不是骗子
他就是个笨蛋
为什么呢
因为角度会跟你
到底这个画面有多宽有关
对 会跟你的周期有关系
你这画面弄得越宽
那角度就越平凡
你的画面弄得越窄
角度就越陡峭
所以他跟角度是
他跟那个几度
20度 30度是无关的
但是你在房间上
你还会看到很多人
在解盘的时候都在讲角度
你看这个45度往上攻
我一看
这是个骗子
他是个骗子
因为他45度往上攻
那到底是几个月
你想说从这边看起来一个月
那一个月这到底是几公分
这个讲角度是骗子
我们讲的都是
我们的邪律就有定义
那邪律怎么定义呢
这边有写
你看
这些83.1、84.7、85.6
这是它每一天的上通道的价格
那我们就看83.1到84.7
这边是多了1.9%
那这1.9%我们就定义为它的邪率
很容易理解
那84.7到85.6是1%
那这1%我们就要做到它的邪率
就这样子
那上通道我们这样
上通道只要是3%以上
沿着上通道3%以上
它都是标普
因为它开很高了
对
那3%
沿着3%走代表每天涨3%
至少
很强
那就很强的意思
所以我们利用这个上通道的斜率
我们就知道说这样股票强不强
我们可以利用上通道的排序
可以排序出来
最近股票哪些比较要
用这方法
那这个
我们还要搭配什么
还要搭配主力买超
筹码来看
只要怎么样
只要带宽载
主力大买
开步领
强力买进的讯号
通常主力买超之前
我们时常在我们的PP上面
PlacePlan
这个不错
今天订阅人数创新高
最近订阅
其实订阅人数创新高
我最开心的不是订阅人数创新高
你猜我猜最开心的
学员贴对账单吗
这也蛮开心的
第一个
我最开心的是学员的序约率创新
对
因为我们每次都讲这个订阅
订阅这种东西蛮现实的
只要做的不顺
一不赚钱就退订
看到最近序约率超高
代表他们真的学的会
一他们有学会
二他们有赚钱
那就开心了
代表我有帮助到他
那不然假如这个退定率很高
代表我自己做的不好
那还要自己虚业率很高
好 那我们再来看
那这个呢 通常关键分点会先买
我们每天都会讲关键分点在做什么
那关键分点呢
它都会比主力还先进场
内部人吗
对 内部人 没错
像我们最近买可乘 我买很多
那我发现好像学员也买很多
为什么 因为我们发现内部人买很多
台南人还有北高雄
他们买很多可乘
他们的成本是190
他们成本190
我们成本是170到180
比内部人还低
哇 那个甜甜价你知道吗
那个双11优惠都没有我们优惠
我们买的比双11优惠还优惠
像今天大盘店可乘也还在涨
就是因为他内部人先买
内部人先买
你就买着就等他后面消息就好了
那我们在这个订阅里面我们还交
通常你在等待的时候
我们在等待我们要不要付利息啊
还不用耶
我们在等待的时候
我们还可以拿到红利
这个蛮有意思啊
这个我们在文章中有教导
我们这一集我们现在讲不灵通道
那你会发现关键分野先买
利害先买
后面主力买 上尾翘
这时候就是我们
这个你假如关键分野先买
你可以先进场
或者是你看到上尾翘的时候
你再进场也可以
你这个联镜场很有效率
这个联镜场就要等它发动
那这个联镜场你觉得 哇 很好
因为股价开始一飞从天
所以其实就要透过这个布林通道加筹锋
其实你胜率就会提高
对 提高很多
刚刚是开布林
然后但是如果它是很窄的话
是不是就先不要理它
因为你可能要等的时间比较久
对 没错
窄的时候你都不用理它
例如说我们举这个例子
这个例子是昌和
昌和在之前整理的时候
这段时间你都不用理他
都不用理
因为股价很无聊又没量
然后我们可以看到吉保护数
因为大家都没耐心了
吉保护数一直往下降
吉保护数往下降代表筹码经过整理
把它沉淀
所以这边你都不用管它
那什么时候管它呢
在这一根
开布林再管他就好
那我们再看
他在整理的时候
你看这边多窄
通道顶30.9通道顶29.9
哇你看29.9到30.9
但是30块涨一块
30块涨一块才涨3%而已
那3%呢
那贷款只有3%
贷款这么窄
一打开就是大行情
所以应该是要持续关注
这样关注
只要打开再进场
打开再进闯
所以各位啊 你不用怕追高
有的人都会怕追高
因为他在这边震荡的时候
通道底29.9 通道底30.9
他可能每天就是这样
30块买 31块卖
他觉得很开心
很开心 每天赚点小钱
有一天31块突破了
变32块 33块
要不要追呢 有些人追不回来
他不敢买
他不敢买回来
我就是买30块的啊
你叫我31 我不想买
32我也不肯 怎么可能买呢
都买30块的 对不对
32块不买
结果你知道吗
他那个不追不追回来后果有多严重
你知道吗
给各位看一下
这个就是这个昌和
他之前的案例
他在这边压缩
后面的一路涨 涨到多少了
涨到了快300
不再涨10倍
这个开步临沿上轨呢
他就是个好买点
那离开上轨呢
我们就部分停利
或者是你越长期报的
你就报到月线下弯
那股票你要赚大钱都是要等出来的
而且要耐震
而且报的够紧所以有几个出场点我们以后也会讲那像这个就是开布林的一个很好的办理一开喷翻了所以有时候不要被你原本第一次买进的价格给
有一个锚定效应
还是要看着用数据来做决策
比较准确
所以我们通常在做交易的时候
我们都会跟选人讲
忘掉你的成本
你要忘掉它 忘记它
你记得的话
赔钱你也痛苦
赔钱的话会让你做出错误的决定
什么叫错误决定呢
你跌下来赔钱你就不想卖
那你不想卖的股票刚好都是在跌下来
不想卖的股票都是空头的股票
那涨上去的股票呢
因为你有赚钱
因为你记得你的成本
我有赚钱就卖掉
涨上去的股票你手上都没有
因为很快就卖掉
你就是因为你的损益去决定你的买卖
那因为损益决定你的买卖
你会变得怎样
你会赚很少
所以还是要学会
小哥这一套用布林通道
就是你直接用这个通道的宽跟窄
来决定买跟卖
对
开布林沿上轨呢
它就好买一点
那你要记得一开你就要进去
你不要开沿上轨长很多
你追没关系
那我跟各位讲
在市场上呢
这个假如有人跟我讲说
我这辈子做股票没有赔过钱的
这种人我看过很多
我这辈子做股票没有赔过钱
为什么
因为下跌我都不卖
报很几
上涨涨一点点我都卖
所以我就没有赔过钱了
这种人呢
我看过的都毕业了
反而是我看到什么人呢
越来越茁壮
去追涨停的
追涨停有时候晚上回来看
哇他今天追涨停
哇赔了800万
他追涨停嘛
结果涨停被挑开赔800万
哇怎么那么笨啊去追涨停
那种我们做统计算他一年赚3亿
你以为他赔800万很多吗
他赚得更多
因为他敢追啊
所以这种开步领的勇敢追啊
人家涨停都敢追
人家开步领干嘛不敢追
涨停你要勇敢追
只要怎么样
只要按照我们所讲的
开步林沿上轨
它就是好买点
一开你就进去买
离开上轨
你在部分停利就好
你可以留一些底单
如果开了过好几天
还需要再去追吗
过好几天
它都还是在上轨
它在上轨的话
因为你一早就进去追了
那就还好
你要不要加码了
看你自己的口袋深度
有的人他一开始试单
那后面就可以加盟
那有的小资组
他可能只有一两笔单而已
那就做第一笔就好
后面就不要再追了
那其实我们通过那个
不离通道除了看买卖点
也可以看出一个趋势
就是多跟空
没错
那多跟空呢
这个非常简单的
不离轨道呢
你可以看出一档股票
多团空头
那多团跟空头呢
我们做短线的
我们都看月线
看月线就够了
月线往上
它就多头
月线往上多头
那股价呢
最好是在上通道跟月线之间震荡
它的意思是说
股价都在月线之上
然后在这中间震荡
你看最近啊
最近这样的股票大成钢
月线往上
股价在月线跟上通道之间震荡
那这种震荡
这个你看上下通道呢
它是一个比较平行的状态
那平行状态你就可以怎么样
你就可以在上轨
你可以稍微卖一些
那个回到月线
这个拉回
你要记得要量缩
拉回量缩
你就可以买一些
到上轨再卖一些
拉回量缩再买一些
你利用这方法
来回做短线就要赚蛮多
这也是一个操作策略
短线的操作策略
没错
那第二个
哇 涨股票
涨股票可惨
这件很惨的一张股票
约线往下
没得意
它的股票叫做没得意
我们都在戏称没得意
因为在报道同学会有人在喊这张股票
通常他们之前在报道同学会喊的
他们还有他们的标语
精神标语
一张不卖 奇迹自来
通常我听到一张不卖旗帜来
后面都是崩盘
只要看到一张不卖旗帜来
我就打电话问我营业
你说这张有几张卷
我全要了
因为通常看到这八个字
都是在讲信念的
股票不能讲信念
股票看的是筹码
讲信念没有用
真的
他们只有在什么时候呢
会团结
一张不卖
我们要团结
他们只有什么时候会团结
就是被融资断头那一天
就很团结
每个人的开盘都被断头
团结出场
那我看这个日子也快到了
因为它今天又跌停
很惨
那这个其实你从筹码看出来
主力在干嘛
主力大卖啊
主力在这边大卖
那最近股价在月线的下面
月线往下了
股价就在月线下
下通道跟月线之间震荡
那这种震荡就空头
这代表弱势
弱势土 空投
那空投有人说
没关系啊
我们去等下一季的财报啊
下期财报会很好
我看过太多财报非常好
隔天跌停了
所以我一点都不看财报
不是说完全不看啦
财报很好你涨多了还是得跌
财报很好
你没有涨那就是涨
所以你要看这股价高还是低
他今年已经涨七十几倍了
还不高了吗
所以这七几倍的股票
这个还在想说能不能涨100多倍
你看筹码是知道
筹码这么烂
主力都在卖超
主力在卖超
股价在月线跟下通话之间
它已经在走空头了
那走空头我看融资还很多
那融资很多这种后面都很惨
那次的股票还有像这个远展
你看一下远展
远展它也是
它在月线往下
股价在月线跟下通话之间震荡
这种就空投
那这种空投呢
它就会走一个节奏
你会看这K棒
这K棒很容易就红黑黑
你看这可能出现一个红
后面就好多个黑
出现一个红
后面就黑
或是出现一个红
后面两个黑三个黑
红黑黑的节奏
就是红黑
后面就黑黑
那这种股票就在走空投
那你假如可以分辨
股票是空投还是多投
那你在做交易就很简单了
至少就赢了一半吧
就好判断了
我们教学人做股票都很简单
股价就像一座山
这座山叫圆展山
它标高158公尺
这有写158
圆展mountain 158
很简单我就问他说
你看一下这座山
你现在是在山的左边还是右边
有些股票正在涨
那代表山頂還沒到
你不曉得山頂在哪裡
那種股票就不要放空
找機會做得多
那像這種股票呢
山頂都出來了
它已經做得很明顯
這山頂已經很久沒出現了
很久沒出現
確定是山頂了
那你要它不是山頂呢
你要它怎麼樣
必須跌下來
震盪打底可能要打個好幾年了
有的震荡打底是18年
被动研究就这样
震荡打底18年
然后提财一来
18年再涨一次
那个才有机会再供
这个再打底要几年我不知道啦
但是我知道
他们的公司派都跑光了
因为他们公司派都声报转让
声报转让我们每天都会研究
也跟学生讲
所以我们的这个PP的含金量非常高
太高了
里面这个多的股票
空的股票
每天我都会打开这个K线给你看
你只要会看
股价是在山的左边还是右边
你就会做的
山的左边就怎么样
找机会爬山找机会进场做多山的右边就找机会干嘛关空找机会下山就这样而已很简单好所以其实小哥的课程
他都做很多的功课
反而是小哥帮会员做功课
然后每天我看晚上都很晚
都还提供很多的数据整理
对
每天都有
我们学生都跟我讲说
没听到
因为我们整理不是写写而已
我们都要录音
录影音
每天的时间就10到
有时候还比较长
有到录影的时间好像叫30分钟
通常都是10到10几分钟
每天跟学生分享
有时候会贴对张单
贴对张单不是为了炫耀
没有啦
因为有时候我们也讲赔钱的案例
贴对张单是跟你讲说我有个交易
因为有的老师讲很多
没在交易
没在交易是讲理论
那么有在交易
我们知道说
你做这个容易赔钱
所以不要做這種
為什麼容易賠錢
因為我賠過啊
我跟你們一樣
我也很想做這個
怎麼這樣很想做這個
我也很想在左邊空他
因為看他不爽嘛
怎麼長那麼多
看他不爽
那我們現在都知道說
你在左邊空失敗機率很高
所以我們都會建議說
這種即便他有很多隔衝
你也不要空他
因為我們有這個慘痛的教訓
我們就知道說什麼容易賺錢
什麼容易賠錢
那比较容易赚钱就是做个过段
所以我们都会整理一些东西
例如说我们整理这种
高档主力卖超股
那每个礼拜还整理一次
那这些股票呢
很多都已经走在山的右边了
那山的右边就是你自己去找的时间点
这个你手上有的
记得你要怎么样
你要早就把他卖掉
手上有的早就会卖掉
那这个比较重要
你看我们之前举的高档主力卖超股的股票
像这一档
网隆高档主力卖超股
在高档主力大卖
那后面你看
这个山顶也出现了
山顶出现了
然后这个月线下弯了
股价都在月线跟下通号之间困
那这个我们在这个PV上面
都有整理解决的位置
那你就只好说
那这种就是找机会去空
刚刚是高档出货国
然后可以做空
那还有所谓的地板股
小哥你来常讲这个词
对地板股我们有个SOP在
我们在下一集教各位怎么样
从地板股的SOP赚钱
因为地板股的胜率在超高的
因为我们有很多学员都是回头课
就上完一堂课他就在找下一堂课上
为什么那么多回头课
因为他知道这招数有效
真的很好的
我们刚刚讲的这个高档出货国
找出来之后呢
你可以做什么事情
这个股票有一个买点一个卖点
那通常你要买股票
你要找主力再买的
只要是大带宽的下轨
就是好卖点
然后呢
假如是高档出货股的话
那什么时候卖点呢
我们就看了
这个步林通道也是有三条
到了上轨都是一个绝佳的好卖点
你看大带宽主力卖
这主力卖
那这边是这个有分点大卖
大带宽主力卖分点大卖
任何反弹道上轨
都是一个绝佳的好卖
逃命点
对 也是逃命点
通常到了月线我们都会想卖
到了上通道我拼命卖
拼命空
每次到了上通道
我们都会有学
假如有放空的
他会在上面哀号
哎呀 怎么日安股票赔钱的
一听到哀号
空爆他
就有人受不了
那都是对我来讲
都是很好的空间
所以我们上课加很多群组
各位你订阅
我们也可以帮你加群组
我们现在加群组大概快60群了
哇 好多
快60群
群组都是500人 满满的
所以快60群
我们每天看这些学人的反应
有人在什么股票
我们去看一下
哎呦 这个点 空点到了
这蛮好玩的
只是说听起来
有些人如果你一开始第一次听
小哥讲这个布林通道
其实会听不太懂
但是如果假设
有没有什么免费的软体
看牌软体
我直接帮我设定好布林通道跟筹码
一起搭配看
就很快知道了
好的
那我先讲第一个免费的
筹码K线
筹码K线不是要钱吗
他几下内免费
就是你小看一点点股票是免费
看比较多他会跟你讲说
那个工程师家有劳小
要养活工程师付点钱
各位这个筹码K线
你记得跟小哥版的订阅
因为小哥版订阅
我们都会送关键分点
是哦
送关键分点超好用的
超重要的
而且我们的这个订阅价钱是市面上最低
然后因为我们用到一个最便宜的方案
那通卡K线里面呢
我们就有
就有这边
然后这边点一下
然后这边有个设定点一下
然后这有个布林轨道
嗯
布林轨道一打开
哇
这边就有布林通道可以看
通卡K线
或者呢
你用三组股市
三组股市也可以哦
三组股市这边有个布林通道
比例我们每天整理大盘的筹码数据
每天告诉你期货在干嘛
外资现货在干嘛
投信在干嘛
散户在干嘛
每天跟你讲
那第二个呢
每天整理主投买主投卖的股票
什么叫主投呢
主力吗 投信
不是那个六合彩
不是那个主投卖
主力跟投信
为什么要主投买
因为有时候投信是帮人家出货
所以你看到主力卖投信买
那也不行
这投信没出货了
所以我们要找主力跟投信一起买
主力跟投信一起卖的股票
哇 这种股票都是马上在动的
正在动的
因为通常订阅我都是做短线的
做短线他们就很喜欢每天做交易
每天做交易的看主投买很重要
那这个第三个呢
每天我们会整理关键分点买进卖出股票
这非常重要
关键分点买
我们靠关键分点赚很多
这两天有没有看到我的订阅里面
有个人靠关键分点赚了500万
我一看吓了一跳
我早知道跟他一样 他是大户
我跟他约定说
下次我们一起来贴那个赚1000万
因为关键人他说
他跟我再细下聊
在市面上他用过很多招式
他说关键分点搭配
现行物理通道来看
是他认为最高的胜率的方式
那这个分享给各位
那我们每天呢
我们都会用关键分点来做
那每天我们还整理申报转让的股票
最近申报转让
申报转让什么意思啊
申报转让就是内部人嘛
内部人卖像最近陆海啊
内部人两拨申报转让
现在每天跌行
内部人都跑了
那每周更新呢
这边写错了
每周更新
月线下弯主力出货
高涨出货
第七个不定期发表秘技
第八个每周五六部已经教学
市面上CPS最高
我们这个有超高的虚约率
上次留存率91.76%
很高耶 超高
哇塞
这一般订杂志的92%
看来也很感动了
更换我们是用电子的
随时不爽手机拿起来
退订就可以按下去了
所以这个91%我觉得很高
没看到那么高
我以前血率大概是80几%
最近血率超高
结果呢
在看这个月的
哇91.93%
哇更高了
床心高
每天会整理这些嘛
那整理完之后我就会告诉你说
这隔天的标题就说
主头买嘉陵大涨
万海涨停
这是前天写的
关键买典范
关键板这种可能是一段时间
郁金光 联电 大涨
我们都是先整理好
后面就告诉你说
这些股票后面发生什么事情
所以大家看了就觉得蛮有意思的
因为它会让你提早知道筹码状况
那股价是后面才反应
那这就是我们要的
做股票不就是希望这个吗
那事后论就没意思了
但是我们是事前研究筹码
所以每天标题
因为你可以看看
蛮有意思的
好
我们今天非常谢谢小哥的分享
如果你也想学会小哥这一套的赚钱通道
还有赚钱方法
欢迎订阅全镇小哥的交易笔记本
财经小学堂
我们下次见
拜拜